dos cosas muy importantes lo primero es
que se abre un espacio de negociación
política con el ejército Liberación
nacional lln donde se habla de un
proceso de paz quiere decir que ellos
podrían aspirar a ganar los mismos
beneficios que tuvo las FARC quiere
decir curales en el congreso tener un
partido político digamos toda esa
cantidad de cosas que se negoció con las
fan ahora el segundo punto es lo que se
llama una acogimiento a la justicia que
es con los demás grupos con las
disidencias de estasfar con las
disidencias de los paramilitares que es
el clan del Golfo y viene una cantidad
de grupos organizados vinculados al
narcotráfico con ellos no se habla de
proceso de paz porque ellos no van a
aspirar al congreso no se les va a dar
ningún partido político no se les va a
dar un estatus político simplemente se
va a negociar con ellos son las penas y
todo el tema de su fortunas y todo el
tema económico que hay alrededor de esto
pero no van a tener una categoría
política Entonces esto es lo más
importante estatus político y
sometimiento a la justicia Néstor una
duda que surge en este contexto por
supuesto
Paz Total no como se la denomina puede
ser una realidad o es más bien una idea
un estado de situación al que se podría
acercar el país pero no lograr de manera
total
no no se va a lograr esto es un gran
esfuerzo hacia la paz que hay que
hacerlo pero no se va a lograr porque de
las disidencias de las fallamos en la
segunda o hasta en la tercera generación
lo mismo pasó hace más de 30 años con el
Cartel de Cali El Cartel de Cali negocio
con el gobierno y apareció el cartel del
Norte del Valle y una nueva espiral de
la violencia entonces lo que vamos a
tener Es que muchos grupos armados irán
negociará con el gobierno Petro Pero los
que están abajo en la pirámide esos van
a armar nuevos grupos y va a seguir Cuál
es el piso esto el negocio del
narcotráfico